et maintenant j'accueille gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
marianne à rien alors je pratique le
sursaut républicain ah ah
je sais pas si c'est efficace mais c'est
ce que je lis partout sur facebook il
faut se mobiliser et sur facebook on en
arrive à des actes d'héroïsme assez
radicaux et qui font du bien j'ai vu
passer un poste quand j'ai appris qu'un
ami de mes amis que j'avais accepté
comme amis s'étaient réjouis d'avoir
voté front national je vais tout de
suite supprimer de mes amis je sais pas
pour vous mais pour moi c'est plus un
ami
[ __ ] le maquis du vercors n'a qu'à
bien se tenir
c'est beau l'engagement au 21ème siècle
cette coûte à un clic hollande ah ouais
après la déculottée électorale enfin à
la déculottée la double pénétration
alors parce qu'il ya municipal avant
donc ça compte double quand je veux dire
là c'est bon de toute façon on sait que
pour le ps la prochaine échéance c'est
la présidentielle de 2000 37
alors
fort de ce bilan notre président il
s'est dit je vais aller négocier avec
l'allemagne
maintenant au moins on sait ce qu'ils
partageaient avec ségolène c'était son
amour pour la science fiction
ces serments le cancre qui vient au
conseil de classe et qui dit bon les
gars moi j'ai fait zéro sur vingt
latéraux il serait peut-être temps de
changer le barème de notation
j'imagine la tronche des autres quand
ils arrivent ils doivent se dire bon
comment lui dire qu'il est mauvais sont
démotivés
non il faut pas il faut pas casser
l'élan mais si tu veux encouragements du
jury tu voi le mec qui fait 13 % quand
les autres ils font 35 40 en moyenne son
prochain grand discours joie non il faut
pas réformer la dictée mais
l'orthographe tu va se mettre ça
en gros le couple franco-allemand ça
ressemble à un pitch classique de
comédie romantique talât bon élève de la
classe un peu rondouillarde qui se prend
d'affection pour l'handicapé que tout le
monde rejette
ctcc cameron diaz son cholestérol qui
flashe sur rain man sans capacité de
calcul
[Applaudissements]
attention ce coup-ci hollande a prévenu
un cette fois-ci moi j'y vais pour
parler d'emploi croissance
d'investissement
parce que jusque là ils leur causait de
quoi
de ces calculs rénaux et du dernier
disque de shakira
percée du front national alors séisme
choc probablement terre raz-de-marée
c'est la semaine haroun tazieff c
est la france est foutue alors une fois
de plus il paraît que les nazis sont à
nos portes
peut-être mais pour une fois qu'ils
marchent vers l'allemagne
alors
certains disent si le fn fait 25% c'est
à cause des abstentionnistes c'est vrai
s'il avait voté le fn aurait fait plus
alors les mauvaises langues disent que
le fn devient un parti de cumulards
c'est la mauvaise foi on peut tout à
fait cumuler un mandat européen avec un
boulot de vigiles ou de maîtres chiens
[Rires]
je ne sais pas
copé copé démissionne ça lui pendait au
nez savais pas à force de réclamer la
démission des autres un moment ça se
retourne contre vous va rien moi je suis
sûr que si robespierre avait réclamé -
tronche à guillotiner il aurait
peut-être encore senti ses doigts de
pied quand il a regardé la foule pour la
dernière fois
parce que l'agent françois je me
permettais ce que la lan françois it
reste quinze jours à la tête de l'ump
faut vraiment en profiter pour ranger ta
chambre
mettre de l'ordre dans tes dossiers
quinze jours pour expédier les affaires
courantes donc en gros détruire les
preuves
qu'un jour c'est peu
je veux dire même en téléchargeant
aujourd'hui mcclean heures windows
restauration j'ai l'intuition que ça
suffira pas alors moi moi je veux bien
tv que faire la procédure parce que moi
tu vas me manquer avec fillon c'était un
couple de temps leur ai dit de finesse
qui tape sur le casse de bourvil c'est
vrai
non je vais t'aider déjà je sais pas si
tu as un mac ou un pc bond apc vu les
initiales
jeu tout quotas ça mais comme tu es un
mec tordu je pense que tu as un pc donc
tu appuies sur power alors tu vas
entendre un bruit de ventilateurs c'est
normal c'est pour aérer les beats
ce que les beats au repos sa fédé ne
faut les régénérer bon
là tu sais que si tu pas faut attendre
un peu si ça traîne un peu c'est normal
si ça traîne beaucoup c'est que tu es
chez free
et là il faut savoir que ton ordinateur
envoie un signal sur le portable d'un
technicien qui doit les brancher un
câble sauvage sur un relais orange et
pour peu que le mec sont en pause café
une fois que c'est à lui mais si tu as
une alerte comme quoi tes contacts ont
disparu ne t'inquiète pas c'est la
confirmation qu'en fait tu es chez
orange
bon
bon a priori tu à l'écran pour toi tu
vas en bas à gauche je sais prend sur
toi c'est un effort
tu as remarqué que les programmes sont
en bas à gauche et la poubelle en bas à
droite comme soit mort en bas à gauche
tu es un petit rond avec un drapeau de
la gay pride
tu vas cliquez dessus tu vas dans
program office to excel powerpoint ou
tout dans excel tu vas dans les tableaux
c'est dans les tableaux il ya des
chiffres avec au minimum 6 0 on est bon
d'ailleurs à priori tu verras c'est
enregistré sous le budget capsules à
café
bon terme à l'internât c'est comme ça
de toi moi jean-françois je sens que tu
vas tomber sur beaucoup de tableaux et
que l'aller-retour bureau corbeil ça va
te prendre deux trois ans minimum
donc mon conseil tu prends ton ordi tu
ouvres ta fenêtre tu passes la tête par
la fenêtre si tu constates qui a bien
six étages en dessous tu balances tout
dans la cour
maintenant six ans j'attends ton ordi tu
remarques laprise s'est arrachée en même
temps
ça fait un court circuit et que ton
armoire un fusible en train de cramer
que ton appartement brûle pas de panique
c'est un signe du destin profite
bonne nouvelle voyage émouvant du pape
il a proposé à shimon perez et mammuth
de à base de prix au vatican c'est
chouette invité un musulman et un juif
prié ensemble c'est en gros c'est comme
demander à un mari cocu et allaman se
prend par la main et de souhaiter à
l'autre d'être très heureux en amour
alors avec l'année et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus